ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد فختام المؤتمر
المناخ بشرم الشيخه قرمو ممثل والوفود
المشاركه في المؤتمر ان شاء الله صندوق
اللي تعويض الخسائر والاضرار التي تتكبدها
دول ناميه جراء التغير المناخي وذلك بعد
اسبوعين من المفاوضات الصعبه التي تجاوزت
الموعد المحدده لختام المؤتمر حيث ظل
المفوضون يعملون لساعات على انهاء النص
النهائي للدفاع فيما قال رئيس القمه سماح
شكري ان العالم كان يتابع المفاوضات وحث
الوفود المشاركه على تبني الارتفاع وبموجب
الاتفاق سنشى صندوق للمناطق الاكثر عرضه
للخطر في العالم على الرغم من عدم وجود
اموال حتى الان لكن المؤتمر لم يرفع
طموحات بشان خفضا بعثه غزوه الاحتباس
الحراري وهي سبب الجدري
ووصفا الامين العام للامم المتحده التي
فقد بانه اشارته سياسيه في حاجه لها لكنه
حضر من ان ذلك ليس كفيا بكل وضوحا
[موسيقى]
نفهم اكثر هذه التساؤلات مع ضيفنا من
بيروت وليد خضوري كاتب عراقي متخصص في
شؤون الطاقه اهلا بك معنا الى هذه النشره
وسيف وليد او الى حلقه بانوراما لهذا
اليوم اييي في الواقعه الشعار قمه المناخ
التي عقدت في شرم الشيخ كان ليس فقط
محاوله
طرح افكار ولكن ايجاد حلول وهذه الحلول
انتقد البعض عدم طرحها بطريقه واضحه هل
تعتقد بان هذا الشعار وقع فعلا تنفيذ او
هناك قبول لهذه الفكره هل نجحت هذه القمه
يعني اولا قمه المناخ ليست سهله لان مفترق
عالم يعني
بدون
المناخ والاثنين في مشاكل فيهم
الوصول الى القرارات حاسمه تاخذ وقت يعني
هذا القرار البارحه طول 30 سنه
خلافات مصالح وكذا والى
الانقاذ دبي
القرار الحقيقه بدون اي هيكل اخوه
فمن
تكاليف ما هي
الخساره الناتجه عن تغير المناخ هذه كل
الامور بعد تقرر
صحيح ولكن لماذا تم رفع مستوى توقعات ما
يخص هذه القمه يعني همم الكل يدرك تفاصيل
لماذا من الاول لم يقال بانه نحن سنحاول
مناقشه افكار لايجاد سبل وتفاصيل قد
نرجعها لفتره همم اخرى لتطبيقها
يعني بدون يكونوا المدفعلين لكن عارفين
جدا ان القضيه الطريق صعب واعر
طيب ما هي ايجابيات مخرجات هذه القمه صحيح
ولكن ما هي خلينا نبدا بالايجابيات سلبيات
على الاقل ايجابيات مخرجات هذه الخامات
كانت مسؤوله عن التغير المناخ وعن المشاكل
الخسائر للدول الناميه نتيجه
الجفاف وغيره يعني هذا الاعتراف
المهم التفاصيل بحث
[موسيقى]
الطريق طويل
المناطق الاكثر عرضه للخطر في العالم ااه
وسيحاول ايجاد حلولهم لكن يقول البعض بان
المناطق الاكثر عرضه للخطر في العالم بهذا
يمثل اسباب او تداعيات همم يمكن ان تاتي
من تدهور المناخ همم ولكن الاصل في
الموضوع هو كيف او سبل ايجاد حلول حقيقيه
للمناخ فهل يمكن همم الحديث عن همم
ايجابيات تتعلق بهذه القمه في هذا الاطار
لا لم يتفقوا قال شيء بهذا الموضوع يعني
يريدون التواصل ارتفاع درجه الحراره درجه
ونصف فقط عن مدى ابتلاع الثوره الصناعيه
درجه الحراره عندنا ما توصلوا لاي قرار
ايجاد حلول في مثل هكذا
يعني الموضوع فيه تفاصيل عديده
الاموال
يعني الى الان الترجمه
هو في عده توقعات مثلا يصير حريق الغابات
في منطقه الامازون هل مسؤوله عن الدول
الكبرى ايضا ان نغنيه نتيجه تغير المناخ
ام لانه لعرض طارق او شيء من الموضوع هذا
اسئله عديده وليست سنه
الجواب يعني
مثل هكذا مواضيع مهمه هل له اسباب سياسيه
بالاساس
مصالح طبعا
اخر مره 2015
لا يوجد جواب على ذلك
لربما لكن النفط
اي شيء حوله حتى الان هناك معادله للنفض
لكن تركوا جانبا كمان
مواضيع يعني تتحمل المزيد من الوقت ولكن
الاولويه تتمثل في ماذا
بالنسبه
ارتفاع درجه الحراره
لكن في نفس الوقت الدول اللي همم
كاتب عراقي متخصص في شؤون الطاقه
السلام عليكم